[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the bonus show up much to the
dismay of many people elon musk has been
named times person of the year
the article written about him is quite
interesting it's it's not all positive
it points out that he's been plagued by
sexual harassment allegations and that
you know commentary about his personal
life being sort of a mess in different
ways but he is indeed times person of
the year people who are upset about this
are upset about it on a number of
different fronts number one the idea
that the richest guy in the world also
is the person of the year it's like of
all the people on earth the one richest
person is also your person of the year
and it sort of seems to be really just
saying
wealth is uh is is the the determining
factor because what are the odds that
the richest guy is also the person of
the year so that's one aspect people
aren't pleased with another aspect has
been his increased uh criticism of not
the left but of government
infrastructure
often more associated with the left than
the right whether it's regulation
whether it's commentaries on
cryptocurrency whether it's been his
sort of resistance to fall in line with
osha and different work-related elements
at factories for tesla etc etc i
have thought of the time person of the
year as increasingly meaningless quite
frankly pat so like i have a hard time
getting too worked up about it because i
already kind of didn't care
but at the same time it is interesting
to see
the write-up that they did and sort of
the way that they see elon musk i don't
know it's like should the richest person
be the person of the year probably not
but i it seems mostly that it's a it's a
reaction to the existing cultural
discussion that already took place
well certainly this day and age the time
person of the year doesn't matter as
much right because we live in a world of
social media and so many different media
outlets you can look up information
about whomever you want to and it's not
like it's one of those things where
the person of the year gets a ton of
attention and you only have a selected
number of media outlets and so this is
your opportunity to learn about this
particular person
so there's that aspect to it and also we
have to remember that just because
you're a person of the year that doesn't
necessarily mean it's a positive thing
like you could be the person of the year
for negative reasons as well i remember
hitler and stalin one person of the year
many decades ago so i don't think that
this is signing off on him being good
for society necessarily so that's
important to point out it's just who's
been most influential and when you look
over the past year i would argue that he
probably does deserve this award because
he has been so incredibly influential
his net worth has jumped up and he now
is like easily the richest person on uh
the planet with reported wealth anyway
he has 300 billion dollars almost which
is just absolutely insane to think about
obviously the tesla share price has
skyrocketed this year so that's another
reason to give it to him they've had
successful launches with spacex and also
he's able to manipulate markets in a way
that we've really never seen before like
maybe him and trump have had this
ability unmatched by anyone else because
you know with what he did with
cryptocurrency like dogecoin and how he
was able to send up and down the price
of bitcoin what we saw over the year um
that's just like never really been seen
before at least not in a long time not
in my recollection so you know with all
of these different aspects all the
different followers that he has he
definitely has a cult of personality
behind him i think it makes sense that
he won the award yeah i mean the thing
is you're not wrong in anything you're
saying but the things you're listing
make exactly the point that i think some
are making which is
he's notorious and powerful
in ways which
are only
according to some people valuable to
society like what i mean by that is
the incredibly increased share price of
tesla stock which i own right like i'm
not complaining but only some people
believe that that's something important
to pay attention to and you could make
the case that like we're not even paying
attention to the right types of people
when we look at person of the year it's
just an argument to be had i'm sort of
just playing devil's advocate and the
[ __ ] the the really crazy thing for me
is
because i don't really think this means
that much it's hard for me to be too
upset about yeah i mean sort of wrapped
up in that is the idea that this has to
have a positive connotation which
historically it hasn't i suppose we can
change it so that you know you have to
actually be doing good for society in
order to win the award but then
obviously
whomever you pick is going to you know
be
reviewed favorably or unfavorably by
different groups of people like you know
last year joe biden and kamala harris
won it and obviously some people liked
that decision other people hated that
decision when donald trump won it there
was the exact same thing and so you know
i think if we just leave it up to who's
been most influential then that's
probably fine going forward and it's
okay to give him the award based on that
and just thinking over the past year
like who would even rival him i can't
think of any specific person like
sometimes they give it to groups of
people like you know they gave it to
whistleblowers one year they gave it to
women who spoke out during the me2 era
in like 2017 uh they gave it to the
computer one year which is sort of
interesting so they can give it to group
sometimes i suppose if you were to give
it to a group this year it would be to
the people who developed the vaccine
right obviously because that's helped us
get back on track to some degree
um with defeating the pandemic but um
yeah when it comes to one specific
person i can't think of anyone else
who's been more influential than elon
musk yeah that's fair it's like if not
him who has been more influential over
the last year so anyway let us know your
thoughts elon musk times person of the
year
you probably remember that derek chovin
former police officer responsible for
the death of george floyd was found
guilty criminally and sentenced to 22
and a half years in the criminal case
he is now also facing a civil rights
case
and the original plea was not guilty but
there is now the belief that tomorrow he
is going to be changing a plea to guilty
changing a plea to guilty he's been
convicted of murder and manslaughter for
the incident where he pinned his knee
against george floyd's neck and
ultimately caused the death of george
floyd the civil rights case now is one
that would if he pleads guilty it would
remove him from a federal trial
involving other officers at well as well
it could increase the total amount of
time he'll spend behind bars
it's not totally clear why this is
happening but one of the explanations
may be
that the other officers have pleaded not
guilty and they were all going to be in
this trial as defendants together by
pleading guilty himself he removes
himself from that group trial and it's
believed that that would be better for
the other defendants in that having the
already criminally convicted uh derek
chauvin there even though it's a new
case and it's not supposed to be
considered the fact that he was already
found guilty it could be bad it could be
prejudicial against the other defendant
so there's the belief that him pleading
guilty removing himself from the federal
trial could be good for the other
defendants we we don't yet really know
that much about this because calls to
his attorneys
were not uh returned from a number of
different media outlets including the
associated press uh there's the idea
that
by taking responsibility he could reduce
his federal sentence but in total it's
likely to go up the other possible
advantage is he might be able to argue
that he serves his entire sentence in
the federal prison system which is
generally speaking less harsh than state
prison and that's something that's a
consideration as well so a lot of
unknowns here but it's it's expected
he's going to change his plea to guilty
right a number of different factors i
wonder if one stands out for him more
than the others like i wonder if he
really does have this or feel this
responsibility to his co-defendants and
doesn't want to lower their chances of
uh you know getting away with what they
did or at least getting a reduced
sentence um so we'll see if that's maybe
what was you know his reasoning with
this but i'm thinking more that he may
just have a sense of being screwed in
all of this as it is like he was already
found guilty on the state charges and
maybe he just suspects that he wouldn't
be able to get acquitted on these
federal charges and so he assesses that
the best course of action for him to get
the minimum amount of prison time is to
just plead guilty take responsibility
and even though yes this is going to
lead to ultimately more prison time for
him overall he would otherwise be
potentially facing even more so this is
probably his best doubt i think that's
probably what's going on here the other
consideration also is in the federal
system there's no parole so in practice
with a with a state sentence you could
expect to at least have a shot at
getting out early you wouldn't in the
federal system but the conditions are
generally considered to be better it's a
mess and i i mean i don't i want to be
clear i don't see him as a victim he did
really bad things and has been convicted
so he deserves it i don't envy being in
a position to have to make these calls
in advance of saying do i chance this or
do i chance that obviously he should
have not gotten himself into this
position in the first place i want to be
clear about that
right and for the people who were upset
over him only getting 22 years in prison
based on the state charges
for one that pretty much was in keeping
with normal recommendations so i
remember going into sentencing and i
think you sort of expressed the same
thing at the time that this would be
about what he would get the 22 years
which uh because of you know good
behavior and all this stuff means he
could get out after 15 years and serve
the remainder of his sentence on parole
but based on what the federal sentencing
guidelines are if he is indeed going to
plead guilty to this uh he could get a
range of 27 to 33 years so ultimately if
you were upset over the fact that he
could be let out of prison after 15
years just know that it may actually be
more like three decades which to some
people sounds a lot more just yeah uh
that is um i mean i i
you know i'm not
i'm not commenting on his guilt which is
pretty clear um but the idea of having
someone say you'll now be removed from
society for 30 years i mean it's a i
don't think i'd be able to handle i
don't know what i would experience if i
was told that but i i
it's i don't it's inconceivable to me
right and he's about 45 years old now i
think so
30 years that would mean that he'd be an
old man when he gets out of prison and
you know certainly some people are going
to argue that's what should happen uh
some people would argue that he should
be put away behind bars for the
remainder of his life other people
suspect that you know because this
wasn't premeditated
and that he didn't explicitly you know
mean to kill george floyd with what he
did then maybe he should have a lesser
sentence maybe something like 10 years
would be more acceptable there's a wide
range of opinions and all this but i
don't think very many of us are saying
that he should just be uh acquitted
entirely no i suppose some people on the
right were arguing that but certainly
not the people in our audience not many
no not in very different circumstances
uh certainly to the to the kyle
rittenhouse trial for sure i'm not going
to spend a ton of time on this because
it's actually going to be something that
as the 2022 midterms get going we are
going to talk about more but when the
recall effort uh really got going
regarding um gavin newsom in california
the attempt to uh recall him and remove
him from office we talked about how
eat low
barriers to launch a recall election is
yet another tool that the right could
weaponize in order to
get their people in office without
really winning the hearts and minds of
the electorate at large and we are now
starting to see
more instances of the american
right-wing weaponizing recalls um back
in 2017
nevada republicans re tried recall
campaigns against three state senators
this year in colorado 10 democratic
state legislators are now facing recall
efforts and we're starting to see this
as a technique
be used more and more to try to remove
democratic lawmakers across the country
we're seeing it in seattle we are seeing
it you know i could give you a long list
and it's also being done
at the school board level and so this is
like a tactic it's hyper local as a way
to take over not just state legislatures
but even who is making decisions about
the schooling
protocol for children around the country
and this it shouldn't surprise us pat
this is much like gerrymandering much
like claiming fraud much like trying to
get ballots thrown out it's a way to try
to get your people in without really
doing the work of winning people on
policy and i go back to what i said
around the new some um election
which is that in too many places it's
too easy to launch a recall election and
because a lot of people never hear about
it the scheduling is often special
election scheduling not scheduled
election scheduling you get your side
disproportionately turning out and it's
a mechanism that needs to be reformed
yeah it's definitely an effective tactic
because obviously if you win the recall
election then that's good you get your
party in power but even if you lose well
you at least took some time away from
the people who were in charge because
they had to focus on the race instead of
doing their job and money so
yeah and money and obviously you know
this the special elections calling those
are uh going to cost the state a lot of
resources or the city and at the local
level a lot of resources so you know the
right tends to win just by instituting
these recall elections even if they
don't ultimately win the race
so obviously it's a good technique for
them to be using but yeah to your point
i think we definitely have to either get
rid of recall elections in different
states and municipalities across the
country or we need to
up the barrier for entry right because
california for example they have a
population of about 40 million people
and i believe they only needed like one
1.2 million signatures to get the gavin
newsom recall election underway and so
yeah i mean obviously that doesn't add
up at all especially when you have an
election where millions and millions of
people are going to be voting in it uh
so yeah something has to change on this
uh i think it does sort of make sense in
some circumstances to have the voters be
able to recall politicians but you can
also argue that there's impeachment
processes and the legislatures can also
go about doing that if there really is
some reason to remove a person in power
so maybe recall elections don't need to
take place anymore obviously we don't
have them in every state and we don't
have them federally so yeah i don't know
if i'm like completely against having
recall elections altogether but we
obviously have to raise the threshold
i'm not against it existing as a
mechanism but i do think the threshold
has to be raised and there needs to be
some way of it's it's a mechanism aside
from raising the threshold the mechanism
favors that party which is
moving for the recall
and
that is something that somehow needs to
be dealt with and i don't know how you
do it you could
whether it's a public notice period with
uh
i don't i don't even know but it's
something that needs to be looked at
with so many of these issues that plague
our politics like gerrymandering we say
like okay well we want to change the
system overall but until we do that we
have to fight fire with fire yeah in
finance the same way we can't
unilaterally disarm do you feel the same
way when it comes to recall elections
like in the meantime should the focus
for democrats be to recall these
republicans in charge for any reason
that they want to come up with or is
that just going to make us look
ridiculous and ultimately not be good
for us because democrats are still
mostly running on policy i don't know
that it's easier to recall republicans
than to just beat them by running good
elections which democrats often don't do
which makes me question whether they
would actually run recalls the right way
anyway so no i actually think
democrats are pretty bad at all of this
stuff but they're sort of equally bad
and so i think that their their their
shot is just as good by trying to just
beat republicans in elections than
recall them
yeah that sounds about right and
obviously you only have so many
resources so anytime that you decide to
focus on a republican politician who
maybe made a bad comment or support a
bad policy that's time away from you
pushing for the things that you want to
push for yeah and we know that you know
certainly negative campaigning has its
place but overall it's better in the
macro to uh be pushing for your own
policy agenda and not wasting your time
on these distractions i agree i agree
curious to hear from the audience what
are your thoughts on recalls should they
exist should democrats
try to use them uh that is going to do
it for today we'll be back tomorrow with
a brand new show and bonus show